new Justice League trailer dropped why I
am here Bed Head and all these less
people are going to see my chips review
better the movies terrible and those
reviews always fun so if you want to
check it out do that talking about the
Justice League trailer it starts out you
see that Bruce Wayne is still he's
getting the team together as we saw in
the last trailer he was saying Superman
would do it but differently has taken a
nap because he's lazy his [ __ ] eyes
not he's dead if you haven't seen it by
now which is building these shoes I
don't want calling all Batman or
anything but I've been there where
you're going on the track you're
climbing the mountain you get to the
table you can see everything your Sheik
of sleep starts vibrating you're like
there's a shrine down there BAM Santa's
with the scenery or monument he's doing
it because there is a threat coming and
wonderful it was like not coming Bruce
here
where are they where's the crow he's he
a montage of the crew Momoa as Aquaman
was like he's a bad as he plops this
fisherman down he saved his life
obviously takes his bottle of booze like
it's on him just saved his ass I'm
pretty sure he can cover a bottle
Captain Morgan cyborg looks cool bit a
bit CGI because these 99% 2gi favorite
in this trailer is to flash I don't know
if it's because I like the show I just
think it looks really cool when he is
burning through the Speed Force trailer
doesn't right man it looks fast as [ __ ]
also that one scene where he's talking
with his dad in the jail is like I've
been here before I've already felt those
bills
I hope the feels that the show gave me
and that closure and resolution in that
arc doesn't compromise the feeling I'm
supposed to get in the movie hack
because I've already been there maybe
it'll actually help the same but once
you land on Plymouth Rock once you know
second time you get it either case this
crew has some work ahead of the Mattamy
Justice League or not metahumans or not
and one guy who's really rich that's a
superpower awesome scene when Barry
Allen's like what you superpower again
Bruce Wayne's like I'm rich that's a
pretty legit superpower I must say
there's a lot a lot of people watch even
if you had superhuman abilities you
would probably use it to a mass wealth
and money he just ahead of the curve
right there he's at the end game of
superheroes but as I was saying
superheroes will not that is one hard as
shitty day at work but there's maybe a
great visual imagery in a trailer that's
really what you get the trailers like
here here's the flavor of the film's not
going to tell you a lot of plot and they
don't so I haven't seen the bad guy
still haven't seen the actual breakdown
of the plot other than the fact that the
Justice League is coming together please
get the stylistic imagery that's what
Zack Snyder is known for that's what
he's good at and that did sure that's
pretty us song totally works too we
talked about
Nerra in the trailer because oh my god
formate redhead
[ __ ] check naira always been check
Amber Heard has forever been perfection
yeah I'd be sure from Disneyland that
says we want the redhead and Pirates of
the Caribbean to warn that what the [ __ ]
am i doing one more time because I love
you there we are I'm a brownstone
they'll [ __ ] we see JK Simmons of
Commissioner Gordon Sam Elliott Oh Sam
Elliott doing in this movie but it's
Commissioner Gordon
he does something like it's really good
to see you playing well with others
again something like that we already
knew that Robin had been a part of this
and he is no longer with us but by
others are the other Robins part of the
serum and by implication they would be
but the translation from comic book to
film though it's not always the same is
Barbara Bergman here is she Batgirl was
she Batgirl is she Oracle to killing Joe
Kapp and so many questions from one
friend but it was certainly cool to see
JK Simmons I'm Elliot cosplay the
trailer is pretty simple in its design
and kick as in his execution to the
Justice League coming together you see
them fighting a bunch of [ __ ] you see
glimpses of the superpowers and what
they can do by Frank laughs I was
excited as hell in the end guys yeah the
first Justice League trailer was awesome
this trailer is awesome
bring on Justice League all these heroes
coming together when it's time to be
alive at least what it's time to be a
nerd analyze alright guys so the new
Joseph swing trailer have you seen it
what did you think about it what was
your favorite part whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]